Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in the fifth chapter of
the chapter of vigilance of Allah's
observation authored by
the sixth narration
The sixth
the 65th narration of the book, the
sixth narration of the chapter, the
narration of
in which the prophet Sam
says,
that three men from Beni is
this could be all the time from
the time of Misam or even before MS all
the way up until our prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was sent. Who is
father of Ysef? He is the father of
Albat.
Ysef and his 11 other brothers. Those
are the 12 forefathers of the 12 tribes
of Israel referred to as the tribes of
Israel. So
he is.
Do we know what is means?
Abdullah
Hearu
remember
we already got that much because we've
taken this before, right?
So,
remember
so we know it's Aramaic. You were close,
very close Aramaic.
However,
il means Allah in Aramaic. So anytime
you say you see il this is us
saying Abdullah
you know Abdullah or or
soil is Allah. Now the first part there
is what changes between
right. So is Allah
that part. So it's a comp a compounded
word. It's one word, one name made up of
two words Abdullah,
right? So is
and it's usually very close to Arabic.
It's Arabic roots.
Let's keep that one on a cliffhanger.
that these three men from Benny is
one that was a leper, a bald man and a
blind man. Allah wished to test them and
so he sent to them an angel meaning in
the form of a man and as we mentioned
each one was given the cure for his
respective ailment and each one was
blessed with the type of wealth that
they asked for. Now we notice traits
about all three of them out the gates.
Number one, the first two are suffering
largely from a cosmetic issue. Their
issue, what they want is not to be able
to function in society. It's not a
necessity that they are asking for. Even
though leprosy is a very terrible
disease that will take a person's life
but leprosy
has many dimensions to it and the
dimension that he is most concerned with
is this leprosy which in his mind is
preventing him from
you know rising in the ranks and
climbing the rungs of higher society.
And so his concern is what people are
thinking of him. And this is a concern
of everyone. Everyone has a reputation
that they to keep up. But when that
becomes a person's only concern and
chief concern,
money and vanity and health, these
things are but a curse upon a person who
is not ready for the test of these
things before they come. We see that the
blind man, however, he asks, he is
blind. He has a physical ailment that is
preventing him from functioning properly
in himself. It is a need, less so a
less so a vanity or a want, but it is a
need. And each one of the first two
chose what would be most
in their mind most appealing to the
public eye. One wants to be a camel o
own many camels. One wants to own much
cattle. Right? Whereas the third he asks
for sheep. It's a very meek animal. It
doesn't have a lot of prestige but it is
more beneficial in many ways than the
first two. It is often overlooked but
usually as the prophet sallallam
says in the narration of
he says
[Silence]
He says that arrogance is most usually
found in the owners of camels, the
shepherds of camels. Why? Because they
spend so much time with camels and
camels have that behavior. Sheep, he
says, sallall.aii Wasam
that humility and humbleness and
meekness is most usually found in the
in the shepherds of sheep in Bkari a
Muslim. And so each of them asked for
these things these these these things
which largely would serve as a vanity.
Now here comes the question. The real
question.
The real question is
when a person
such as in this situation these two
first men also in the Quran
Allah tells us of a people who ask Allah
for wealth and they say
if you give us this wealth we will
give it for the sake of Allah and we
will be of the righteous.
But then he tells us that they fail in
this once they are given the wealth. He
says, "Subhan
that they say
[Silence]
that after they receive this wealth that
they asked for, they become stingy. They
withhold it and they turn away and they
become arrogant. Why is that? Why do
they fail that test?
The question
goes back to the state of being upon
making the request.
Doesn't mean that a person soon as they
get wealth they're always going to
become corrupted. Not true at all. many
very wealthy
men throughout history
Islamic history and human history.
Some of the greatest of mankind have
been very wealthy individuals. As a
matter of fact, the most wealthiest man
in all of history
was one of the most righteous men in
history. And he was a prophet of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And he asked for
wealth, didn't he? He asked Allah
subhanahaala
for
a a a dominion,
such a kingship of such prestige and
such esteem that no other person will
ever have the likes of after him. Allah
gave him Allah gave him of all that this
world had to offer and he did good with
it. So why is it that this one when he
asks he's given he becomes better?
This one when he asks and he is given he
becomes far worse.
The answer lies in the state of being
upon asking.
When Sle man made that request,
who was he at the time of the request,
he was a a very good man. He was a
prophet of Allah, a righteous man, all
of the good traits. And so when he was
given that wealth, it only increased
those traits. However, these other
folks, they
were not very good people when they
asked for this wealth.
They as they asked for this wealth for
the purposes of vanity.
They asked for this wealth and they were
holding off being good until the right
circumstances presented themselves.
Ysefam when he was in prison he didn't
say
as soon as I get out of prison I'll be
good right now. Things you know it's not
set the way I need it. So, I'm going to
cut corners, but as soon as I get out of
here, I'm going to be a great guy after
that. I'm going to be a righteous guy
after that. That's what his brothers
said, right? Almost verbatim.
That get rid of Yousef and then after
that you will be righteous men. Why
aren't you righteous now? Well, because
of Ysef. It's not the right
circumstances. We need to make the right
circumstances to be good.
That is not the nature of righteousness.
The nature of righteousness, Allah tells
us
that they give in both ease and in
hardship. They are constantly doing good
with whatever they are given. They're
not waiting for any circumstances,
the right circumstances to come for them
to start being good. They play their
part. no matter what the circumstances
are. And so when they are given wealth,
it only increases them. However, someone
who's not good and then says only if I'm
given am I going to be good. This person
is only going to get worse with
you know obscene amounts of money,
obscene amounts of resources. This is
only going to increase them in their
ability to disobey Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala came to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then
gave each of these men the first one a
pregnant she camel the second a pregnant
cow the third a pregnant sheep and
each of them started to breed their
respective animal until the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam says says
till each of them had a valley's fill of
that animal. The first one had a
valley's fill of camels and the second a
valley's fill
of cattle and the third a valley's fill
of sheep. So how much time has gone by?
Decades. decades.
And so
the first man who was
leper, he is still a leper at heart,
right?
The angel then came to him in the form
that he first had when the angel first
met him. Came to him in the form of a
poor leper.
and he said, "I just need one camel to
get where I'm going." And he said,
"I just have too many responsibilities.
I can't I can't make it." And so he then
said,
"Weren't you
a leper that people were disgusted at
the sight of a poor man?" But then Allah
gave you and then gave you this
beautiful complexion and clear skin. He
said,
He said, "You got me confused with
someone else. I've always had this
wealth and and and in my family, we've
always been a wealthy family. I I
inherited this from my father and he
from his father and so forth." And so he
wouldn't even acknowledge
where he was and what Allah had done for
him. And so the critical statement,
the critical statement, the angel then
said to him,
"If you are lying,
then I ask Allah
to take you back to where you came from,
to go right back to where you were on
that fateful day
and
that is what happened. I mean the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam doesn't
tell us he leaves it to it's insinuated
that that is what has occurred. Why?
Because Allah says,
"If you all thank me, I shall increase
you."
And if you are ungrateful, then
indeed my punishment is very
is very terrible. And so
how long did it take for him to go back
to being that man?
Probably
another few decades just as it built up
to this. And finally it came around full
circle. He was sitting there with his
leprosy back, his wealth all gone and
not one person and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala not there. And that actually is
the best case scenario.
Best case scenario for him. Yes, the
best case scenario. Why? Because maybe
maybe in that situation
when he finds himself back where he
started, he can look back and understand
why he is in that situation and turn and
repent to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. The
worst case scenario, he only gets more
wealthy. The worst case scenario, he
only gets more healthy. The worst case
scenario, he he only lives longer and
longer and becomes more entitled and
more ungrateful and more obscenely
wealthy and able to and able to uphold
that illusion until Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala takes him from between his satin
sheets. That is the worst case scenario.
[Arabic recitation]